Jennifer Lopez is 50 today I do want to
celebrate it's a big one for me I just
want to do something in the afternoon
you know something nice nothing crazy
but you know it just definitely
celebrate well she got the afternoon
thing right but nothing crazy that
didn't really pan out
JLo hit the half-century mark like the
boss of Miami Beach
[Music]
jewel I 24th is now known as Jennifer
Lopez day this afternoon the mayor
presented JLo with keys to the city
[Applause]
[Music]
among her party people in attendance
eleven year old twins Max and Emmy J
Lo's parents and her always beating
fiance earlier in the day a rod brought
her to tears with this ridiculously
romantic Instagram post hi baby girl
I just want to wish you a happy birthday
you're simply the best partner in life
the more than one and a half minute
video montage included never-before-seen
video of their engagement
[Music]
she even got a Twitter shoutout from
Oprah the 50s everything you've been
meaning to be so what else keeps JLo
looking like a woman half her age here's
all the age defying beauty secrets JLo
has told us do it do it you totally
totally to do it aware
yes I'm 50 but I also feel very useful
back in a hot dog yeah back it up
I say mantras to myself I'm youthful and
timeless than every Asian and that's my
thing
her other secret being the mom of twins
these kids keep me young on J Lo's list
of no nose smoking caffeine alcohol and
Sun tanning I live healthy you know I'm
havin ever really drank I don't smoke
I've haven't taken a lot of Sun I'm sure
all that stuff is helping me now in my
late 20s on her to-do list a healthy
diet that includes lots of green veggies
daily meditation and sleep but she does
allow the occasional cheat day I
actually like sugar very much but I do
try to be careful with it for sure for
sure you have moderation balance that's
the key to life right tomorrow JLo hits
the stage in Miami for her final three
it's my party shows Saturday's finale
will also be a celebration for a rock I
have off on my birthday but then I have
to do three shows in a row in Miami and
the last one is on his birthday so we'll
probably have a party that night
[Music]